jared cole who is far and away the ace
of the yanks and may just be the ace
of the american league sick start on the
year and
the numbers are really good especially
broken bat ground ball urchella
over to first and a nice easy one two
three in tyler glass now ten walks and
fifteen
in the third inning two outs in the
bottom of the first now it will be mike
ford
against glass now on the ground and
right out there for
the short right g-man choi
and there's a shot back into deep right
and that baby is
out of here home run off the bat of
g-man choi
and it gives the rays an early lead
joy's second home run of the year
well one nothing tampa here's the
shortstop willie adamus
down goes adamus looking two-way first
strikeout for cole
here's kevin kiermeier lefty-hitter
struck him
out swinging second strikeout for
garrett however one run one hits one
nothing tampa
frazier's gonna be the hitter now the
two two on its way to frazier
fastball lifted in the air right center
field charging in
coming in as margot he makes the basket
catch uh waist high
to retire manuel margot
leads off popped up
urchella did he make the play
does he have it yes he does what a play
by archela for the first
out a lot of times when you go over to
that visiting dugout
you're not going to get much help but he
found the wall he reached in
and was head over heels and actually got
some help there from the race
the batter is mike zunino
shot back into center hicks will go to
the track
and that one is out of here zunino
center field goes deep for the third
time this year
and the rays have a two-nothing lead
luke boyd walked in the first inning
that one's driven to right field and
deep
going back more go on the track at the
wall
sia into the second deck the other way
a solo shot for boyd his ninth home run
of the season
yankees on the board it's 2-1 raids now
on the field his choice martinez at
first
here's the 1-2 and i really like that
pitch struck him out swinging high
fastball
it's two outs two on two one raise
strike three kier meyer down looking he
does not like the call
but a big strikeout for cole 50 pitches
for
tyler towards the 1-2 breaking wall now
that one that's a great curve check
swing strike three looked like a strike
and dive bombed into the dirt for his
fourth k
one out sanchez has seen five pitches in
this game
all four strikes down on three pitches
his first time that's the high leg kick
of the pitch strength recall with a
fastball
he got sanchez looking for the curve and
the fastball was buying before he was
ready
a couple of three pitch strikeouts of
sanchez by glass now who has by far
his best inning of the night margo
popped the third his first time oh that
was the play where
archelaud draped himself over the
railing and made a phenomenal catch
now cole's 02 struck him outside of
really a dandy
down and away here's zunino this home
run is a difference in the game right
now
swing and a miss got him two odds that's
a big run at second base
diaz has grounded out twice swinging and
a miss
garrett cole strikes out the side he's
got eight for the game starting with
brett gardner
strike three right there at the knees
98. what a pitch right there here's tyro
estrada
there you go swinging the mouse on the
breaking ball 2-1
tampa bay and we have a classic pitchers
duel on the modifier scoreboard 2-5-0
for tampa bay 1-1-0 for the yankees
swing and a miss that was cole's i think
was his 99th [ __ ]
bottom of the sixth inning so it's hicks
hits sharply
and it's a fair ball and it goes into
the corner hicks rounds first he's going
to second
ball gets away from margot hicks round
second he's going to third
and he is going to make it with a triple
well the yankees have first and
third michelle has hit two fly balls to
center
back up the middle fly ball
right field tagging his hicks margot has
a good arm
he makes the catch here's the throw
here's the play at the plate
it's a tie game a sac fly for urchella
and it's 2-2
bottom of the line up here and the
one-two
rounded up the middle oh grabbed there
by hershela
beautiful play he took a base hit away
from kiermeier for the first out
amazing play right here because that's
not where he's accustomed to playing
with the shift he's all the way on the
right side of second base
so one on and one out and here's the
catcher mike zunino strike three
zunino down looking strikeout number 10
for cole for the yankee right-hander 109
pitches a season high well
cole was not elated about being taken
out of this game
well garrett certainly wears his heart
on his sleeve he was not trying to hide
his displeasure so let's see if britain
can get meadows run a ghost
swing and a miss meadows down on strikes
and that'll do it here in the seven so
it comes down to three and two
man at third two outs bottom of the
seventh
is fairbanks against hicks
and he got him looking and dropped that
one in there for
strike three first and third now with
nobody out
the hitter will be jose martinez the
one-two
grounded to third they're gonna come
home and they get diaz for the first out
of the inning
grosso is gonna be the pinch hitter for
choi
hot shot base head center field
low's on his way to the plate hicks will
make the throw back to second
brandon lau scores martinez goes to
third
brasso comes through again and the rage
lead three to two
will the adamus men on the corners
and the wider the other way into right
field charged by
talkman martinez will score the rays
have a 4-2 lead
so the yankees have the tying ones on
here in the bottom of the ninth inning
so here it is estrada the yankees last
hope
estrada he got him to chase it and the
rays win this one
a 4-2 final